Вітаю вас, друзі!
Сьогодні у нас урок фізики,
8 клас і його з вами проведу я,
Валентина Албул,
вчитель фізики.
Темою нашого сьогоднішнього уроку
буде “Електричний струм”.
Це поняття вам знайоме,
всі ми до нього звикли і
не помічаємо тієї роботи,
яку він для нас виконує.
Давайте уявімо собі на півхвилини,
що струм електричний вимкнули.
Що сталося?
Ми всі залежні від нього.
У нас не працюють мобільні телефони,
якщо вони працювали,
то ми не зможемо їх
зарядити через якийсь час,
у нас не працюють
холодильники, телевізори і т. д.
Отже, ми живимо вже залежні
від електричного струму,
ми іноді боїмося його.
Давайте ми спробуємо дізнатися з вами,
що ж таке електричний струм,
що ж таке електричне коло і
поговоримо з вами про силу струму.
Ми з вами знаємо,
що існують заряджені частинки і
існують два види електричних зарядів,
вони взаємодіють,
притягуються і відштовхуються.
Ми скажемо з вами, що
таке електричний струм.
Що ж це таке?
Його визначають,
як напрямлений рух заряджених частинок.
Що ж це за частинки?
Носіями заряду, як їх ще називають,
можуть бути позитивні та
негативні йони та електрони.
Ці частинки входять до складу атома.
Ви можете спитати,
чи може бути носієм
заряду протон або нейтрон?
Ні, це частинки, які входять
до складу ядра атома,
а ядро дуже складно розділити.
Отже, електричний струм
це напрямлений рух заряджених частинок.
Ми з вами звикли до того,
що в наші прилади
вмонтовані металеві провідники,
тому нам буде цікаво,
як же рухається електричний
струм по металевих провідниках.
До речі, він може рухатися
не тільки по металу,
наша блискавка, яку ми теж боїмося іноді,
це теж електричний струм,
електричний розряд в повітрі.
Проте поговоримо зараз про
електричний струм в металах.
Що ж це таке?
В основі металу лежить кристалічна ґратка,
давайте ми спробуємо намалювати це.
Це у нас такий ніби провідник,
дротик, я спробую його зобразити.
Кристалічна ґратка,
тобто в узлах кристалічної
ґратки мають знаходитися атоми.
Проте так природа захотіла,
що електрони деякі з дальніх орбіт,
вони пішли від свого атому,
перетворивши його на позитивні йони.
Давайте ми з вами спробуємо
відтворити таку кристалічну ґратку металу.
Дивитися на дошку.
Ось вони, позитивні йони.
А куди поділися електрони?
А вони пішли у вільне плавання.
Ось вони такі крапочки, мінуси.
Електрони мають знак мінус,
як ви знаєте, і вони рухаються
безпорядно хаотично.
Пригадайте, будь ласка, ліхтар влітку,
навколо нього такі комахи,
вони безпорядно хаотично рухаються,
і раптом подув вітер і їх понесло.
Чи зупинили б вони
свій безпорядний рух? Ні.
Вони продовжують рух безпорядний,
хаотичний, проте вони
рухаються під дією сили вітру.
Ось ми утворюємо з вами електричне поле.
І в цьому електричному полі,
яке утворюється в просторі,
знаходиться наш провідник.
Наші електрони,
до якого полюсу вони будуть рухатися?
Вони мають знак мінус,
тому вони будуть притягуватися
до протилежного заряду,
до плюсу.
Тобто їх рух стане вже напрямлений.
Отже, електричний струм в металах
це напрямлений рух вільних електронів.
Дуже важливо звернути
увагу на слово вільні.
Якщо електрони знаходилися в атомі,
то б нікуди вони не рухалися.
Отже, електричний струм в металах
це напрямлений рух вільних електронів.
Які ж умови маються створюватися для того,
щоб електричний струм протікав?
Уявимо собі таку аналогію протікання води,
течія води по трубах.
Людина звикла до того,
що вона має щось побачити та зрозуміти,
побачити, як рухаються
електрони в провіднику, не можна.
Подивіться, будь ласка, ось у
мене декілька таких пристроїв.
Де тут електрони, де їх можна побачити?
Ви знаєте, що речовини по їх
здатності проводити електричний струм
поділяють на провідники,
діелектрики, напівпровідники.
До діелектриків відносяться:
скло, пластик,
дистильована вода, повітря.
Що ж це таке?
Це такі речовини, які не
проводять електричний струм.
Напівпровідники в звичайних умовах
не здатні проводити електричний струм.
Проте якщо їх нагріти або освітити,
вони здатні проводити електричний струм
і це зараз використовується дуже часто.
Як же ми можемо побачити,
що електричний струм протікає?
Давайте ми побачимо,
які умови мають виконуватися для того,
щоб електричний струм протікав?
Отже, щоб рідина протікала по трубі,
вона, по-перше, має там бути.
Тобто ось тут в металі мають
бути вільні заряджені частинки.
Ми вже знаємо, що такими
частинками є електрони.
Саме електрони в металі.
Проте вони рухаються безпорядно.
Чи протікає зараз по цьому
стрижню електричний струм?
Я дотикаюся до нього
рукою. Ні, він не пече.
Для того, щоб він протікав, він має
знаходитися в електричному полі.
Отже, друга умова для того,
щоб протікав електричний струм,
це наявність електричного поля.
Для того, щоб електричний
струм протікав не одну мить,
як це іноді буває,
перетекли електрони, все,
зрівнялися заряди, і далі їм нікуди
текти, має бути замкнене коло.
Як знаєте, вода в фонтані - вона циркулює:
і та сама вода піднімається і опускається.
Тобто має бути замкненим електричне коло.
Ще раз. Умови існування
електричного струму.
По-перше, мають бути в
наявності вільні електричні заряди,
по-друге, має бути
обов’язково електричне поле,
щоб ці заряджені частинки
рухалися в певному напрямку
і, по-третє, електричне
коло має бути замкнене коло,
воно за визначенням слова
говорить про замкненість.
Пристрої, в яких
утворюються електричне поле,
називаються джерелом струму
або джерелом електричного поля.
Що ж це таке?
Які вони можуть бути?
В джерелі електричного
струму мають розділятися заряди
для того, щоб в якомусь місці
концентрувалися додатні заряди,
в якомусь місці
концентрувалися від’ємні заряди.
І це електричне поле має
існувати достатньо довго,
щоб вимушувати рухатися заряджені
вільні частинки в певному напрямку.
Ми знаємо, що в результаті тертя
тіла можуть електризуватися
і навколо цих заряджених
тіл вже існує електричне поле.
Отже, в такому випадку
механічна енергія
перетворюється на електричну.
Давайте ми спробуємо з вами подивитися.
Ось такий пристрій.
Його називають ще динамо-машина.
Я зараз буду крутити це колесо,
ось цей шків,
який приєднаний до генератора,
який буде виробляти електричний струм.
Отже, давайте ми подивимося як це працює.
Мені прийдеться трішечки
покрутити ось таку ручку.
Ви бачите, що механічна
енергія перетворюється
на електричну енергію.
Ми це побачили,
отже ми побачили один вид перетворення.
Давайте ми подивимося
ще один вид перетворювання.
Зараз я спробую.
У мене такий є лимончик.
Лимончик це кислота,
я зараз спробую в цей
лимон встромити залізний цвях
і мідний дротик.
Це різні метали, у них
різна кристалічна ґратка
і у мене є такий прилад,
який показує - чи є струм,
чи немає.
Називається він гальванометр,
він індикує маленькі струми,
маленькі за величиною.
Ви бачите, що стрілка
гальванометра зараз стоїть на нулі,
вона може відхилятися
як вліво, так і вправо.
Я замкну наше коло і подивимося
чи відхиляється наша стрілка?
Ви бачите - вона відхилилася до максимуму.
Я розмикаю це коло.
А тепер давайте спробуємо
поміняти полярність.
Я червоний дротик
приєдную до мідного стрижня,
а чорний - до цвяха.
Подивіться, струм потік в інший бік.
Отже, електричний струм має напрямок
і ми бачимо, що він може змінюватися.
Хімічна реакція відбувається
в цьому електроні
і лимон, як і деякі інші пристрої,
в лимоні перетворюється хімічна енергія
на електричну енергію.
Отже, ще раз:
джерело струму - це такий пристрій,
в якому будь-який вид енергії
перетворюється на електричний.
Там виконується робота
сторонніх до електричних сил,
які вимушують одні частинки
рухатися умовно в один бік,
а протилежні за зарядом частинки,
в протилежній бік.
Далі ми сьогодні поговоримо
ще про дії електричного струму.
Що це означає?
Ми не можемо бачити,
ми не можемо уявити рух зарядів.
Як в цьому переконатися,
що струм у привіднику тече?
А він виконує якісь дії,
іноді ми відчуваємо це на собі.
Проте це буває іноді шкідливо,
іноді це буває і корисно,
коли ми, припустимо,
лікуємося за допомогою електрофорезу.
Отже, дії електричного струму.
Давайте ми побачимо ось
таку дію електричного струму.
Дивіться, це у мене теж джерело струму,
це літієвий акумулятор.
Я спробую зараз ось
таким чином вам показати,
а ви скажете, яка ж це дія.
Яку дію зараз виконує електричний струм?
Спробуємо з вами зробити такий світлофор
з трьома кольорами.
Світлова дія електричного струму,
світлодіоди і батарейка.
Це наші споживачі, ми
будемо так їх називати,
а це - джерело струму.
Ось тут генератор електричного струму.
Він зараз допоможе продемонструвати
теплову дію електричного струму.
Дивіться, у мене тут
зібране вже електричне коло
і є тут спіраль, така подібна спіраль,
тільки з вольфраму, є
в лампі розжарювання.
Давайте ми подивимося з вами,
я зараз підключаю генератор,
джерело струму до цього кола.
Я вмикаю його і дивіться,
тут у мене є вмикач або ключ,
таке є в кожній оселі
щоб включити лампочку.
Я замикаю коло.
По-перше, зверніть увагу,
що прореагувала стрілка компаса.
По-друге, ви бачите, що
накалюється ця спіраль.
Щоб вам було зручніше бачити,
я вам зроблю такий чорний екран.
Спіраль накалилась, теплова
дія електричного струму,
магнітна дія електричного струму.
Я розімкну це коло,
стрілка зараз зупиниться,
а я спробую поміняти полярність,
і ми подивимося
чи прореагує на це наша стрілка компаса.
Я поміняла полярність, замикаю коло.
Подивіться, будь ласка,
стрілка компаса
відхилилась в протилежній бік,
а спіраль так само нагрівається.
Отже, ми з вами подивилися
теплову дію електричного струму.
Ми не бачимо з вами, що
тут рухаються електрони.
Проте ми бачимо, що наша
спіраль не тільки нагрілася,
гаряче навіть на відстані.
Вона накалилася і почала світитися.
Ми побачили з вами магнітну
дію електричного струму,
ми побачили світлову
дію електричного струму.
Звичайний ліхтарик нам теж демонструє її.
Ми побачили з вами хімічну
дію електричного струму.
Електричний струм було
винайдено ще у 18 столітті
і з ним почали проводити досліди,
а електрони винайшли
наприкінці 19-го століття.
Вчені подумали, якщо є два види зарядів,
то потрібно взяти якісь з них за основу.
І прийняли, що напрямок
електричного струму
співпадає з напрямком руху
позитивно заряджених частин.
Так досі і вважають.
Зараз ми з вами поговоримо
про електричні кола.
Бо кожен електричний прилад
має своє електричне коло,
його можна замикати і розмикати.
Праска, пральна машина,
телевізор, будь-яка.
Ми з вами подивимося,
як можна зображати електричне коло.
Ось подивіться, будь ласка,
воно вже є зібране на
дошці, воно складене.
З чого - зараз ми подивимося.
Ось такі затискачі,
до нього зараз буде
приєднане джерело струму.
Я звідси його вимкну
і приєднаю його ось сюди.
До речі,
прийнято червоний дротик
підключати до плюса,
а синій або чорний - до мінуса.
Отже, ми з вами знаємо,
що ось тут у нас плюс,
давайте ми навіть напишемо,
що тут у нас плюс, а тут - мінус.
В якості споживача,
який має бути обов’язково
в електричному колі,
бо будь-яке електричне коло
складається для користувача,
а користувач - це людина,
а людина скористується якимось споживачем.
Нехай це буде лампа,
нехай це буде холодильник,
нехай це буде будь-що.
Отже, у нас зараз тут лампа.
Вмикач, ми подивимося зараз,
чи буде горіти наша лампочка.
Я замикаю коло, наша лампочка загорілася.
Я розмикаю коло і
спробую поміняти місцями,
ми з вами подивимося - чи
залежить робота лампочки
від зміни полярності.
Лампочці байдуже де плюс, де мінус.
А тепер ми з вами спробуємо
накреслити цю електричну схему.
Це у нас з вами гальванічний елемент.
Так він позначається - джерело струму.
І спробуємо намалювати цю схему
в тому ж порядку, в
якому вона тут вказана.
Давайте ми намалюємо гальванічний елемент,
до речі, у нас він так зображений.
Дивіться, жирна коротка смужка
позначає мінус джерела струму.
Довга вертикальна смужка - це плюс,
і одразу позначаю їх.
Далі, подивіться, будь ласка,
обов’язково прийнято електричні схеми,
які є кресленням електричного кола,
графічним зображенням електричного кола,
бо обов’язково будь-який
електричний прилад
має мати електричну схему,
щоб можна було налагодити якісь помилки,
які там виявилися.
Далі під прямим кутом
я намагаюся це намалювати.
Вмикач або ключ я малюю ось так.
Якщо я опущу його вниз,
тоді коло замкнеться.
Тут у нас була лампочка і я замикаю коло.
Ось така найпростіша електрична схема.
Це звичайний ліхтарик.
Величина, яка характеризує
електричний струм силою струму.
Ми бачимо з вами, що є така
формула для цієї величини.
Позначається вона літерою І
і називається силою струму.
Ми бачимо знайомі нам букви,
Q - це електричний заряд
і час протікання електричного заряду.
Я прописую цю формулу на дошці.
Латинська транскрипція букви І
це сила струму.
Вона дорівнює відношенню
електричного заряду,
який протікає через
поперечний переріз провідника,
за одиницю часу.
В системі СІ
ця одиниця часу - це секунда.
Ми можемо сказати,
що сила струму характеризує
електричний заряд,
який протікає через
поперечний переріз провідника
за одну секунду.
Ця величина вимірюється в Амперах.
Ампер, так як і Кулон,
пишеться з великої літери,
тому що ці одиниці
названі на честь вчених.
Ампер - французький вчений,
який досліджував електричний струм
і досліджував взаємодію провідників,
якими тече електричний струм.
Отже, Ампер – це основна
одиниця в системі СІ
як і метр, кілограм, секунда.
Отже, один Ампер - це є Кулон,
поділений на секунду.
Якщо через поперечний переріз провідника
протікає заряд за одну секунду,
то кажуть, що сила струму
дорівнює один Ампер.
Як ще можна охарактеризувати цю величину?
Це є швидкість протікання
електричного заряду
через поперечний переріз провідника.
Давайте знову поговоримо
про протікання води по трубах.
Ми звикли, що вода тече по трубах,
що це теж є замкнуте коло
і що є такі лічильники-водоміри,
які ставляться в певних
частинах цього кола
і вимірюють скільки води витратили,
скільки пройшло за секунду.
А тепер ми з вами поговоримо про прилад,
нібито той водомір,
який має вимірювати силу струму.
Тобто він рахує
скільки пройшло зарядів
через поперечний переріз
провідника за одну секунду.
Називається він Амперметр.
Ампер це одиниця вимірювання сили струму,
а амперметр міряє ампери.
Якщо у нас тут з вами текла вода,
де б ми встановили водомір,
щоб він пропускав кількість води
і не заважав цій воді текти?
Давайте ми розірвемо це коло.
Ми з вами міняємо і дивіться уважно,
як я під’єдную Амперметр.
Я вмикаю його послідовно в коло
і від плюсу джерела струму
ми маємо прийти до плюса Амперметра.
Тобто якщо шкала Амперметра така,
що нуль на шкалі зліва,
то ми маємо обов’язково
дотримуватися полярності,
інакше струм потече в зворотній бік
і стрілка буде зашкалювати.
Отже, від плюса джерела струму
ми йдемо до плюса Амперметра.
Коло замкнулося:
чорний провідник іде на мінус,
ось тут написано мінус,
а так як у нас тут декілька шкал,
то ми вибираємо самі
яку шкалу ми хочемо використати
і тут у нас стоять плюси.
Межа вимірювання у
верхньої шкали три Ампери,
у нижньої шкали - один Ампер.
Я підключила до одного Амперу.
Отже, максимальний струм буде один Ампер.
Давайте поміряємо струм,
який протікає у нашій лампочці.
0.1 Ампера проходить через нашу лампочку.
Я вимикаю.
Якщо ми підключимо гальванометр,
ми бачимо тут нулик посередині,
тут не буде важливо
буде струм від’ємний чи додатній.
В такому випадку можна міняти полярність.
В тому випадку, коли нулик
шкали знаходиться з краю,
обов’язково потрібно
дотримуватися полярності.
Подивіться, будь ласка,
формула для сили струму.
Але іноді потрібно визначити заряд,
який протікає через
поперечний переріз провідника
і час, який може працювати
той чи інший прилад.
І ми маємо з вами перетворити цю формулу,
щоб ми визначали і заряд,
і час протікання струму.
Ви знаєте, що в фізиці
використовують такий трикутник.
Зверху у нас добуток.
А добуток це заряд.
У віконичках у нас сила
і час протікання струму.
Тут між ними знак множення,
а тут — ділення.
Отже, я закриваю рукою невідому величину
і бачу, щоб знайти час
це буде відношення заряду до сили струму.
Як же визначити сам заряд?
Ми знаємо, що між віконцями знак множення.
Я пишу нижче -
заряд дорівнює добутку
сили струму на час.
Ось так ми працюємо з формулами.
Отже, сьогодні ми дізналися
про електричний струм.
Ми знаємо в якому напрямку він тече,
в яких одиницях вимірюється.
Ми знаємо прилад для
вимірювання електричного струму.
Як накреслити електричну схему
та будувати електричне коло.
На сьогодні наш урок закінчено.
А ось і дзвоник.
Дякую вам за урок. До побачення.